hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts point-of-care genomics a
new horizon and personalized healthcare
presented by Marcel dinger he is the
founding CEO of genome one head of the
kinghorn center for clinical genomics at
the Garvan Institute of Medical Research
and conjoint associate professor at UNSW
Australia
I am Marjorie torrents of labyrinth and
I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
weeds
lagoon's is a leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation does click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen will answer as many of your
questions since we have time for it at
the end of the presentation if you know
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the commercial or
at the bottom or center of your screen
or use the ask a question box to let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is education and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
quality' process to obtain your credits
please join me in welcoming dr. Marcel
digger I will now turn the presentation
over hi everyone and and welcome to this
presentation it's a it's really exciting
to be able to give this to to the group
today because I'm I've got a so some
really interesting new work that I'm
going to present and and we're we're and
our thoughts at the moment on
point-of-care genomics and and this new
horizon and personalized to health care
ok so let's get started and so the human
genome as some of you will be aware in
you may recall from your days back in
high school biology we have 40
X chromosomes and about six billion base
pairs of DNA that are that are wrapped
around amongst these across these across
these different chromosomes in different
parts 23 of those chromosomes that are
inherited from from your mother and 23
from your father so all of the
information that's in there is really
what powers everything around the
development of an individual right from
a single cell individual from when your
conceives all the way through to through
to being Peters child a baby and growing
up and it's actually really remarkable
to think about all of that information
and just how how much of it is in there
in terms of how it changes throughout
your lifetime and even the the subtle
things like things like your eyesight my
deteriorate or hairlines receding the
graying of a beard as you can see in the
image there of the two identical twins
there of the of just how many of these
these different characteristics of
individuals are actually ultimately
programs inside our DNA the burger is
huge we're talking about you know as I
said it's six billion characters of
information if you actually to kind of
put that in context if you had like
printed that out in a nine point font on
it on just normal sized sheets of paper
it would stack up to like three hundred
feet or a hundred meters tall so there's
an enormous amount of information in
there of course most of this information
is about what makes us human and what
makes us different to to two other
species and life on Earth but it's also
the differences between that in the DNA
codes there's between yourself and
somebody else varies by about four
million or so of those six billion
characters so that explained most of the
of the variation between two individuals
and most of this variation is normal
however a lot of the information that's
here can also have an impact on health
and disease and that's they're really
interested in genomics from a healthcare
perspective so this goes through some of
these things so
the human genome as I'm as I mentioned
actually underpins most diseases and
influences how we respond to virtually
any medical condition or treatment so I
guess what I'm saying there is that
we're not just talking about like
individual hereditary diseases but even
the way that our body respond to the
seeds like whether that's how our body
responds to different kinds of
medications or how our bodies even
respond to other medical interventions
some such a surgery or or infection so
the real value that we see now in the
human genome goes beyond just the
diagnosis substance ease but also how it
can be used to inform clinical care
particularly of course in areas of
despair disease and cancer one of the
areas I'm going to focus on today is the
expectation and anticipation of the
ability to be able to sequence a genome
which has come down so much over the
last 10 or 20 years now it's possible to
capture this data quite easily but
interpreting it and using it in
healthcare still remains a huge
challenge and that's part of what I'm
going to present today so worldwide this
is becoming increasingly recognized
there's extraordinary
impact the human genome sequencing has
had so worldwide governments are and
have invested billions and billions of
dollars trying to understand what the
impacts are of genomics in healthcare so
especially some of the major projects
like in in England the genomics England
project in France there's a major major
project the NIH are running a huge
project and called the all of us
initiative and so on and of course
including in Australia where there are
several initiatives involved in the
application and implementation of
genomics in healthcare so as I said the
genomes price of genome sequencing has
come down enormous ly over the last 10
or 15 years this is mostly a consequence
of next-generation sequencing of
massively parallel sequencing which
really was touted to become available in
2007 since then there's been a hyper
exponential drop in the cost of whole
genome sequencing right down to where we
are today
which is where the data can be generated
that is the whole genome sequenced for
about a thousand dollars so what makes
this test quite so remarkable and and
distinct from other tests that have come
before it it's really that it covers
many other tests that have previously
existed so there's one test to hold you
know sequencing tests potentially
replaces in fact does replace thousands
of existing genetic tests many of which
would not ordinarily even have been
available in the healthcare to
healthcare practitioners so in this
regard there is so much more information
in terms of a a geneticist or health
care practitioner doesn't need to know
nearly as much as they would have
formerly needed to understand to be able
to even work out which tests to order
which is what the how we would have been
how things were done prior to the access
to whole genome sequencing so you can
kind of the so called hypothesis free
diagnosis we have all the information in
front of you and then can really make
the best possible diagnosis and
healthcare decisions from there there's
also of course the ability to reanalyze
data this is very unusual most tests you
know you tests are done but then there's
no further opportunity to really make
use of that information but the genome
is unique like this that as we learn
more about the genome we can keep
testing and again and again and querying
it again and again for for new health
information it also of course has huge
value outside the medical system in a
research context so the other
characteristic that makes whole genome
sequencing which you know makes peculiar
or very different to other technologies
that have that have come before it is
that it has an impact over so many
different areas of life and healthcare
all the way from from planning a
planning and child in the context of
carry screening all the way through to
understanding what caused the death of
an individual now so-called molecular
autopsy and everything in between as
well so understanding like the
diagnosing cancer guiding the treatment
of cancer on
standing which diseases we're
predisposed to diagnosing diseases which
medications we respond differently to
and so on
okay so never talk about some of the key
opportunities that are really in front
of us today in terms of how genomics can
be used in healthcare so the main one of
course is the diagnosis of genetic
disease as you might expect the
sequencing the whole genome is a very
powerful way of diagnosing disease
cancer of course the molecular
stratification of cancer makes the
sequencing tumor a tumor DNA we can
understand what's actually what the
drivers are of a particular cancer and
then use that information to to actually
guide the treatment of cancer and
finally of course and this is perhaps
one of the more exciting areas that
really holds the most promise is in
terms of its impact on healthcare is
actually to prevent disease and to
really personalize treatment based on
genetic information all right so first
I'll just speak briefly about genetic
disease so what are the main
opportunities and this is really in the
areas of rare disease rare disease one
tillich monta 2% of individuals are born
with the severe genetic disease many of
these are undiagnosed diagnosis can be
incredibly powerful for managing
managing the symptoms or managing the
conditions of a for a patient by having
a diagnosis it can also be very valuable
for the reproductive choices for future
children from a from a family
the diagnostic rates have been
transformative in this area with
previously many of these diseases remain
undiagnosed
but now diagnostic rates are in the area
of around 50% and this is an area that
has already really started to have a
significant role in in healthcare so
what are the challenges in in doing this
this is as I mentioned at the start of
the presentation there are billions and
billions of characters of information
our genome but the real challenge what
we're really trying to work out is which
one of these is actually the cause of a
disease it's a real needle in a haystack
kind of problem where you've got
millions of variants of things that are
just different between
individuals but what we're really
interested in is which one is the cause
of the disease and many of us carry
actually damaging mutations in our genes
in any case so it can be very difficult
to work out what's just normal things
that our body is able to compensate for
versus those that are actually
pathogenic in the real cause of disease
so genome one what we were trying to
achieve and this is very similar to
other organizations and the genomic
testing field is to try and make this
actually accessible to healthcare
obviously a health care practitioner can
look at thousands and thousands of of of
characters of DNA or to interpret a
genome so it has to be made really easy
so the idea is that is developing really
a genetic test that makes it simple to
to order a test and to return that
information back in a way that it's
actually meaningful to a health care
practitioner and they can use it to
guide the the management of their
patient's condition so this was a a very
long process for us and we were one of
the first companies in the world along
those that that really brought this this
brought this together and made genome
sequencing something that could be done
in a safe responsible approach that
fitted in with the existing healthcare
system I won't go through all the
details today of there are all the
different steps but in essence it's
everything from counseling a patient in
terms of what they can expect and what
the implications are having a genome
sequence all the way through to
sequencing the genome analyzing the data
and working out as I mentioned before
what the pathogenic changes are in the
genome and then ultimately putting this
into a report that can be acted on so we
try to do this through a platform that
we've developed and where effectively
you take not just the genome but you
also use all of the information that's
available well the so called phenotype
to be able to drive the interpretation
of the genome to be able to find the
most accurate possible answer so today
in our setting we
we're able to diagnose a huge range of
different diseases from inherited
diseases childhood syndromes kidney
renal conditions and immunological
disorders and so on but as well as that
we've now also started working towards
how we can actually predict disease in
individuals as well by looking for genes
that increase their that significantly
increase the susceptibility to disease
by such as carrying disease and cancer
and also those that lead to an adverse
response to medications so I'm just
going to give some context to this I'm
going to give an example of a of a
diagnosis that was undertaken at our and
our facility when we launched a couple
of years ago so this was a a boy his
name was Alan we've got permission to
use the story of course and at the age
of three had been diagnosed with a very
rare condition which was an immune an
autoimmune disorder as attacking his own
blood cells it was not understood what
the cause was as the disease nor how to
treat the condition the age of seven as
options were really starting to become
very limited for the family into a
program to have his genome sequenced
with us and so the became very urgent
but was and it was in intensive care of
the at the time and said there was a
real need for a diagnosis we were able
to find a diagnosis for a particular
gene called Li ba and this actually
connected to a coincidentally almost to
a drug that is actually been trialed to
to treat patients with this with the
same condition and it had promising
results so in this case the the drug did
work and it had a really transformative
impact on Ellen's condition and actually
really put it put them put it out of
date with the condition out of danger to
his life and enabled them to stop going
back to school came for the first time
so this was really shows this just how
powerful this type of technology can be
and how it can really change change
lives
as you can see on the next slide it says
mrs. Allen with his father literally in
the pack home and playing the flight
sabers and basically doing the kinds of
things that normal boys do so to give
some sort of examples of this and how
it's being applied in in our context so
we've we've undertaken sequencing as
individuals with intellectual
disabilities in an in an area Liverpool
Hospital which is a large Regional
Hospital just southwest of Sydney now
here we again just looked at what was
the impact of of being able to provide
diagnosis for these children and so we
sequence about 26 or so families and as
you can see we diagnosed about 12
definitively some of these which had had
been undergone genetic and investigate
investigations for years and years
sometimes as long as 17 years in the
most extreme case we were able to find a
diagnosis and just a matter of weeks
using using genome sequencing technology
so there really just makes the point of
just how powerful this this can be okay
so moving on I'm now just gonna talk
briefly about what one of the other
areas I won't talk about cancer today
but I'm going to talk about disease
prevention and treatment personalization
which is a really exciting domain in
genomics at the moment so genome one
develops a a test and this was involved
with using expertise from genetic
pathologists molecular pathologists
clinical geneticists and in scientific
expertise to really try to answer that
question what can we test in an
individual's genome that doesn't
actually have any particular symptoms
for disease so and where the information
could be returned in a way that it was
actually actionable by health care
practitioners so there's difference from
many other kinds of testing that just
that are more associative associated
with the diseases where we're really
looking for mutations and here
and in jeans that have a high chance
that if there is a damaging mutation
that will cause disease so in this test
fit is for about 169 genes associated
with cardiovascular conditions 56
associated of cancer predisposition and
hundreds of that are involved in testing
for for adverse reactions or unusual
responses to two medications all of
these conditions that we test for are
for treatable conditions or where a
patient or an individual can be managed
to reduce the likelihood or incidence of
that disease really with the objective
of leading a longer and healthier life
by having knowledge of this information
about eugenia so here are two examples
that give some guess my dear around this
so of people that we've individuals
their names have changed here that we've
that we've had seen through our service
and gives just an example of the impact
that it's had on these individuals lives
so first example we'll just go through
is Linda who was had a genome sequenced
and Tom etherion that could cause a
reaction to eternal anesthetic so she
hadn't actually had a journal anesthetic
itself before but she had a child who
needed to have a son who having it's a
particular procedure at tonsillectomy
which would require general anesthetic
so she was able to inform the anisa just
about that and they were able to
accordingly change the type of
anesthetic used on her son to avoid any
risk of having an early and an adverse
reaction to that em aesthetic and in the
second example there is Malcolm where it
also has genome sequenced and he had
very high cholesterol levels and we were
able to identify that he did actually
have a genetic variant that was linked
with familial hypercholesterolemia which
can increase the risk of cardiovascular
disease as a result of this information
and component with this family
you know misreport we were able to guide
or as healthcare practitioners were able
to guide the the best possible
medication to to manage this condition
so there's a really nice examples of
where you wouldn't have been aware of
this information without in the absence
of this genetic information and it's
really made a difference to how these
patient's health was managed so in all
this that's become more of a routine
part of healthcare so we're seeing all
the time like I said as I mentioned we
test now for just a few hundred genes
but in the future we'll it's very likely
we'll be able to test for more and more
different sorts of conditions and be
able to return these in a valuable way
back to the health care healthcare
practice practitioners so if we look at
these curves then as you can see there
on the left we are seeing a rapid
decrease in the cost of sequencing and
in parallel we're seeing an increase in
the value of the clinical value of a
genome and I think there will at some
point reach a where these curves really
intersect and where it will be truly
valuable for any individual to have
their to have their genome sequenced and
to use this information to guide the
care picture on the right there just
gives an idea just how fast the growth
is in our understanding of different
genetic conditions so this just shows
the number of genes associated with
schizophrenia and how this has changed
just over the last 10 or so years on the
eight or nine years going from
understanding very little of the genetic
swiftness of of this condition to having
she now having a good understanding of
the genetics of a much better
understanding the genetics of
schizophrenia so one of the main
challenges that it's really faced that
we do face today in using genetic
information is really in in the spectrum
of understanding which to see which
genetic variants are of what we call
monogenic which means that a single
change is is the cause of a condition
and what the impact is of environment on
this so some conditions like say for
example to take an extreme like cystic
fibrosis and
to kill a change in the in the CFTR gene
which causes cystic fibrosis can will
mean that if there changes there it will
always lead to disease but there are
other genes where single changes don't
fully cause that or may or may not cause
the disease this is so-called penetrance
so some of the cardiovascular conditions
for example it could good examples of
those where changes in the genome may or
manifest the disease and some
individuals and not on others and then
across this as well it's not just the
environment that has the impact on this
but it can be other genes that that
individuals carry that can have an
impact on how different variations
impacts on disease and this is really
where a lot of the research is happening
today is to understand more and more
about what the individual changes in
genome caused and how we can better
predict how changes to the genome relate
to disease okay so the way that we kind
of think about this and to go back to
where as I mentioned earlier is how do
we how do we go about this how do we go
from these there's these having these
six billion characters and of
information and working out which one is
related to a particular disorder so what
we do is we really are bringing together
these three threads of information we
can look at the genes themselves and and
and the variants of them and predict
what impact a variant may have on a gene
and in turn what impact that will have
on the shape of the protein that it
codes so that's the so-called
pathogenicity of the variant we
similarly we can also look at at
filtering variants by looking what is
what is actually normal was what it
exists commonly in a healthy population
and by looking at comparing one
individual's genome to the genome of
thousands of people we can actually make
it start to predict and understand the
difference between what is normal
variation or damaging variation and
finally is the introduction and use of
phenotypic information so that's the
actual physical characteristics
themselves and this can be a really
important component of being able to
accurately
interpreting genome so this is really
about asking the right question at the
right time to get the best possible
answer from a genetic analysis so this
is an area that's been a challenging one
because of course sequencing in genomes
I mentioned before is not necessarily
there difficult and and now is becoming
increasingly commoditized in terms of
being able to sequence a whole genome is
the instrumentations certainly available
to do this there are many laboratories
around the world that can sequence
sequence genomes but analyzing the
genome and actually extracting the
health value from it as a very very
different story where the nature of the
analyses can have an enormous impact on
the overall cost at the ends so if
you're spending tens or hundreds of
hours of specialist time to interpret a
genome it's not scalable and of course
ultimately makes for a very expensive
service so compromise needs to be found
in terms of how we develop analytic
solutions and other automated approaches
to being able to sort accurately and
effectively interpret genomes but do it
in a cost-effective way
so as I mentioned before one of the ways
that we do this is by actually is is how
we can variance on from from the
millions to to the individual ones that
have an impact so sabeti and this is
something that we did at the governance
Institute where I'm where I also have a
position as well as the chena one and
where we sequenced the genomes of 3,000
healthy individuals these were
individuals that had no history of
they're all over the age of 75
they had no history of cardiac disease
or cancer or any other neurological
disease so it could be sort of you know
somewhat defined as being in healthy
individuals without any strong readers
positions of disease because I guess
they've made it back to the age of 75
without being affected by any of these
so we can actually use this now like as
a reference so when we sequence a genome
of
of an individual asking a particular
question we can compare it to these
thousands of genomes to get a feeling
for which which we're picking up
variants that are particularly
pathogenic or not so this was a huge
computational exercise we had to call
variant variants from from these three
thousand genomes and compare them and
for the statistics there you can see on
the screen to give an idea of the scale
of this we used the Amazon Cloud to do
this in combined this was really pretty
big data almost a petabyte of data that
we that we put onto the cloud and we
were using thousands and thousands of
CPUs all in parallel to make a lot of
computations to extract the differences
from these thousands of genomes out to
create this sort of database of of
information so this information is
available and there's a platform that we
call that we call vectors the victors
cohort platform it's available at SGC
John Kavanagh Lau it's freely accessible
and you can actually browse through
these these thousands of genomes and and
look at the individual variations across
different genes the other area as I
mentioned and that's also one that we
were with we've invest a lot in and I
think it's a really important area for
interpreting genomes and that's being
able to understand the phenotype of the
individual and their conditions so this
is a particularly challenging area is to
to really make use of because phenotype
unlike unlike the unlike the language I
suppose that we use for Geno's are just
a is TCG's there is no common language
to describe different sorts of
conditions just to give an example of
that this is a you know if you think
about a condition such as this is a
technical term for this is a skin
condition is Palo planter hyperkeratosis
you know an individual if they looked at
it it sort of looks like how its hand
see Michael
the skin on your hands if you the same
condition in a mouse which is obviously
where where a lot of research is done in
and medical researchers time to
understand the impact of different types
of cheat of variations of genes you
would manifest itself as ulcerated pause
how do how do you bring all of these
kinds of things together so a lot of the
work that that we've done and others is
to try and unite this kind of
terminology and and harmonize it in a
way that we can actually use it in in
machine'll in systems where computers
can then effectively read more of this
phenotypic information and make use of
it to drive the interpretation of the
genome
so essentially what our process starts
to look like is that we can take now
information from electronic medical
records so we can extract common
terminology from this and use this the
structure listen to we call structured
phenotypes so you may have like a
particular term like macro safley which
is a technical term for a large here and
someone else monocle term it's is big
eared and this all becomes harmonized
into a single single medical term this
can then be related to genes which can
then in turn be used to I guess um
target which genes where to look at the
genome so what we do is that we use
information from the medical record to
ultimately drive the interpretation of
the gene of the genome itself and this
provides a more accurate and direct way
of being able to analyze genes and and
return information that's truly relevant
to the condition at back to the
healthcare practitioner so to kind of
move from there I just wanted to briefly
mention some of the impacts around this
in and in both how clinical care and
terms of what where the in-game supposed
kind of is how this relates to medical
research and in the industry of the
actual testing process so I guess in
previously pre genomics
you know developing a new medical test
was a long complicated process there you
would sequence dozens of individuals you
try to add you know identify a common
genetic cause and then ultimately
develop test and then that test would be
rolled out into clinical care but what
we're really seeing today is that this
type of testing is is being developed
now in a very different way because we
can divert it you would consider it's
the whole genome almost in a short space
of time and we have all the information
there we can actually translate new
research very very quickly into the
clinic so a new disease association
doesn't necessarily any longer require
the development of a new test the test
is already there it's just a genome
sequence which we can do it really then
just becomes the application of
interpreting the application of the
information to interpret the genome as
quickly as possible so this really
becomes much more about managing
information and managing data and it
does become about the traditional files
testing which brings me to the last part
of the talk that I wanted to talk about
which is where we really see this all
going so today as I said it's I mean
it's a it's an amazing feat of how far
we've come over the last 10 years it is
now possible to have your genome
sequenced but it's still its application
as I mentioned earlier is really focused
very strongly around genetic disease and
and it's and it's learners to to some
extent by access to these very
specialist practitioners so the cartoon
at the top there just really shows the
sequence of events that has to happen
today in order to get a genetic
diagnosis you have a specialist referral
specialist counseling yeah if we clicked
a blood sample sequence the genome
sequence interpreted reporters and then
it ends up going back again to the GP
and eventually leading to a clinical
action in this whole process still can
take you know months to go through so to
really have a profound impact on
healthcare what we what we
anticipate the future really holds is
where a genome is ultimately sequence
just once in our lifetime and we
certainly do see the cost of genome
sequencing is going to keep coming down
you know to the point where and you know
if you think of an analogy to other
kinds of technologies like photography
which used to be expensive to take a
photo but now it's just like you think
of your smartphone and a photo was
something that it effectively costs
almost nothing today
we certainly can see that the genome
sequencing will go in a similar
direction and at some point it will
become almost a trivial amount of costs
the sequence of the genome so this data
will be available to us but then it
really comes down to how we use it and
the ideal is of course that once the
information is there that in any routine
visit to a fit to a doctor or specialist
or any any other decision involving your
health that the genome can be actually
be used in in the context to be able to
guide your care so for example if you're
having a medication prescribed that your
genome is being interrogated to to see
if that medication is going to be
metabolized in a normal way by you as a
as an individual with a different
medication may be more appropriate and
so on so is this true personalization of
healthcare based on genomic information
that where we see that the future is is
hitting which is a just a pretty
remarkable thing to start to think about
and how this can will ultimately be
implemented so going forwards into the
future
I guess that we're seeing more and more
it's not just about genome sequencing
we're also starting to see medical
devices having an increasing impact on
on the health system whereby these
wearable devices such as massive bio
monitors and you know things like Fitbit
and so on and these other yet bio
monitoring devices and wearable
devices adjustables that are all able to
take real kind of like almost real-time
information about about an individual
about your health and how this is now
saying to become more and more
intersected and made use of by combining
it also with genomic information like so
show to really truly start to
personalize this and it really starts to
transform the way that we think about
the way that healthcare that we interact
with the healthcare system machine
learning and deep data analytics is
becoming a increasingly a major part of
all of this it's becoming I guess more
and more clear as well that it's not
it's no longer possible for for any
particular any single practitioner to
have all of the knowledge they need with
all of this new information it's now
become available and so what we're
actually saying to see now is that is
that computers and and deep learning are
really anticipated to have a much larger
role involved in directing and in
informing healthcare so where we see the
future going really is that all of the
data that's out there from from
individuals will become increasingly
both aggregators and and used to to
really inform inform clinical decision
making in an optimal world I guess what
we would see is that the information
from and outcomes from from from any
patient interaction are actually used to
inform the next patient and patient
interaction so for example knowing which
medications work best for which
conditions on a on a population scale
and actually using it information to
then actually start to drive how how the
health of individuals has managed based
both on their genome and all of the
information that's available so to start
to sort of wrap that up and to start to
think about what the future of of
healthcare might look like and so
certainly what we foresee is a is that
the genome will start to increasingly
inform healthcare and then this should
be able to extend well beyond just you
know rare disease and genetic disease
diagnosis but also to other domains
cancer cardiology nephrology neurology
of the Molony orthodontics and you know
even things and ultimately general
practice and lifestyle where genomic
information can be used to to drive all
of the or inform the decision-making of
these domains so in summary and I'll
wrap up with this is that whole genome
sequencing is a powerful technology it's
a single test that can diagnose
potentially any heritable disease it can
tailor drug choices and it can also be
used for productive purposes to predict
health outcomes and better manage an
individual's health it's contextual
reading a genome in and of itself can be
useful in some in some situations but by
far the most effective way of
interpreting a genome is actually
bringing it into the context of other
health information and using other end
of health information to proceed direct
genome queries or the way that we
interrogate interpret the genome is a
huge scientific challenge still ahead of
us and decoding the genome we typically
only use maybe one to two percent of
that of our whole genome in in a genetic
interpretation when we interpret the
genome most of it you know basically
science still doesn't really understand
what it all does many many of the
millions of variants in the genome we
don't actually understand their
functions for how they relate to health
and disease there's still a lot to learn
going ahead but given the millions of
genomes that are being sequenced around
the world I think there is an
acceleration to understanding more and
more of how the genome works so another
interesting area I think is that
clinical genomics has has been
remarkable in the way that it was drawn
to get a clinical and research domains
and it's really been quite disruptive to
both so we've certainly seen this in our
Center the bringing together of our
medical research and and Clinical
Investigation has been really powerful
and I think it's actually a fundamental
component of of precision medicine is
being able to bring together both those
clinical threads
and and the latest medical research
really bringing out together and that's
really where the most power I think will
come from and how how genomic
information is used in the future
because ultimately we we are actually
trying to use you know information to
from an individual's and as always this
is this challenge in bringing together
all of the evidence that's needed to to
drive interpretations which is
traditionally always been based on large
clinical trials and bit and and studies
but now what we're really doing is we're
saying well what does this mean for this
individual and what is the variations in
this to no means for them so I'll leave
with that remain forever excited about
about genomics and its potential to to
transform lives happy to take any
questions you can contact me on Twitter
or by email or or just visit our website
thank you thank you dr. Marcel jr. for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started our first question
is what do you think might be the
implications of this sort of testing on
a person's health and life insurance
thanks that's a great question so it the
implications are different you know we
know I've seen in different different
countries around the world in Australia
which I can speak to is that health
insurance which is like a non risk rated
insurance is community rated there's no
impact there on on health insurance but
on life insurance other forms of risk
rated insurance the kind of information
can be used in the same way that other
health information like you know family
history is used today governments around
the world and some have already put this
into place actually now made it so that
so the genetic information and
predispositions information of to
disease can't be used to to affect
premiums in life and other forms of a
spread of insurance and I think that
other countries will follow suit and
that certainly seems to be the trend
that's happening around the world thank
you for that answer
our next question is when gene then
genome testing will become mainstream so
yeah as I indicated there's some real
challenges around this at the moment and
most of them are associated with
workforce that is the individuals that
are actually available to be able to
either interpret a genome or to be able
to properly counsel individuals around
this so and I think it will be really
central for I think a key part of this
will be software and integration into
into medical record systems to be able
to really both empower physicians but
similarly also individuals and patients
to be able to use this information I
suppose there's a lunging it hint but I
think that we are she's starting to see
more and more of this happening now so
perhaps over the next five or ten years
we will really start to see the genomics
lose more and more eating okay it looks
like we have time for one more question
our next question is what is the
difference between whole genome
sequencing and genetic tests you can
order from the internet like 23 enemy so
whole genome sequencing really actually
sensors all of the really the full
genome also 2 billion characters whereas
the some of the so-called
direct-to-consumer test it's just since
they can be ordered on the Internet
you know normally quite cheap as well
maybe for one or two hundred dollars
those are not whole genome tests they
to actually look at a few a very small
since maybe 0.1% of variations in the
human genome and a correlate or
associate these with different kinds of
disease and then information actually
comes more from from population scale
analyses and they don't actually they
don't actually identify or these by
lines they don't actually identify
individual damaging these patients to
genes so they can actually predict with
any real accuracy or medical accuracy
what what genetic conditions an
individual is affected by so they can be
used for diagnosis basically and many of
them are not supporting or aren't come
used in the context of actually guiding
healthcare either
I would like to once again thank dr.
Marcel jr. for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots from making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August of
2018 you'll receive an email from
Lavery's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
when you shut that announcement with
your colleagues to my home is today's
lime fest that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye